strawberry baby
[Applause]
you ready
stormy Webster's ready to party and
support her dad Travis Scott at his
London concert but nothing's cuter than
the four-year-old adorably lighting up
when the rapper gives her a sweet shout
out
[Music]
[Applause]
you ready
judging from stormy's reaction Travis
knows how to make his and Kylie Jenner's
little girl feel special I love it
Kylie and stormy support in the audience
is a big deal for Travis
[Applause]
it marks the Goosebumps rapper's first
solo headlining performance nine months
after the AstroWorld tragedy which left
10 people dead and hundreds injured I'm
honestly just devastated and I could
never imagine anything like this just
happening naturally Kylie documented the
family weekend in London on social media
showing off her skin tight denim look
while setting the mood with some Travis
Tunes
2020 but I can't see nobody
one eye open Illuminati and Kylie stayed
close by her man here's the couple
holding hands backstage and packing on
the PDA in Travis's dressing room yeah
seems like Travis is feeling the love
following his return to the big stage
[Music]
Kylie and NBA star James Harden cheered
him on after his performance and its
Champagne Showers all around
the Webster Jenner crew has a lot to
celebrate these days Kylie kicked off
her 25th birthday celebration a few days
early across the pond
[Music]
but of course we love seeing the whole
family step out
[Music]
earlier this year stormy stole the show
per usual at the 2022 Billboard Music
Awards
Trevor you enjoying your family night
out
Kylie are you enjoying Mom and Dad
nights out hi stormy
hi storm how cute is she stormy
continues to be the cutest and recently
got a promotion to Big Sis back in
February Travis and Kylie welcomed their
second child a baby boy whose name has
yet to be revealed we have some um we
have some really strong options but we
haven't officially changed we have some
placeholders so before I officially
change it I just want to be short you're
seeing that little personality
[Music]
thank you